what's going on guys this is rob and
let's explain the ending
of loki episode number two so here's the
thing
you guys were right about it being lady
loki honestly i wanted it to be icole i
really really really did i love the
character of ikel
it makes sense to this lady loki she's
cast for the show i cole is not there
were some rumors about characters that
were going to appear in the show and
their castings had not quite been
announced yet
we also still have rumors that like
immortus is going to show up we don't
definitively know if that's the case
honestly we're two episodes in i imagine
by this point
if the characters haven't been cast
they're not going to be or at least if
the casting announcements haven't come
out yet they're not going to appear in
the show maybe it'll just be one of
those weird little surprise things i
mean if you guys remember in one
division evan peters character was a
mystery character that we didn't know he
was there until he appeared
so little things like that can happen
over the course of a show's life but the
important thing here is that
it really is lady loki so let's explain
lady loki for a second as
always if you guys want a more
comprehensive and in-depth explanation
on this character
make sure you check out my video over at
comments explained when you get done
watching this one but lady loki is
basically the result of what happened
when loki took over the body of seth so
here's how this played out in marvel
comics they wanted to essentially rework
thor so they removed him from the
landscape by having him destroy the
world tree
after the events of ragnarok this in
effect wiped all the asgardians from
existence
including odin who was actually already
dead at that point he died against
certain in the 1990s the important thing
here is that following that and a couple
years after
thor ended up returning back to life and
then rebuilt asgard and broxton oklahoma
the asgardians were not truly dead
instead their spiritual essences were
reborn in human bodies
and so thor had to travel around the
world find different asgardians and
basically wake them up
starting with heimdall who could help
them find everybody else the body that
was meant for sith
was intercepted by loki and so loki came
back and sift's body and that's why loki
appears to be a chick lasted for a
little while had some cool moments he
formed his own avengers team so they
could fight the throne which is kind of
a cool thing and then eventually loki
dies during siege and then he's reborn
as kid loki slash eichel so that's more
or less the quick and dirty history of
lady loki
but i think she's ultimately doing
exactly what i
said she was going to do which was
detonating all these different bombs
these little reset chargers
throughout the entirety of the time
stream now this raises a couple
different questions one what's rock's
carton
two why do this in the first place and
three
what's the benefit of it so talk about
rock's car for a second in mobile comics
they have a company called roxon oil
they're like the amazon of marvel comics
they've got their hands on everything
and they're always into some
really shady and bad stuff if it's a
criminal thing
they have a hand in it right like
they're pretty bad folks obviously
they're designed to also be an allegory
for walmart as well they do
kind of represent just like the negative
aspects of corporate america as kind of
what they are but they're pretty bad
folks they're actually led by a guy
named dario agger who is essentially the
minotaur
he died but he's a pretty cool character
as far as why it is that lady loki's
doing this
we don't entirely know i still stick by
the fact that i think that she's a nexus
being but we're only two episodes into
the show and she's already been revealed
what this means is we've got four
episodes left there's a lot of
information you can get from
four hours of content so i think lady
loki's motivations are going to be
pretty big and i think the revelation
she's going to give us
are going to be pretty intense as well
now i say this for a couple different
reasons
one because we've never seen the time
keepers and i don't know about you guys
but the time keepers seem suss man like
they seem like something's off
right like i think they're bad guys i
think loki's statement when he was
talking to mobius and he said if there's
anything i've learned is that bad guys
are not always bad guys
and good guys are not always good guys i
think that's hitting to the fact
that the time keepers are not really
what they say they are here's something
else that might actually blow your mind
the time keepers might not actually
exist they might have been killed
a long time ago or even just the
animation that we got about them is 100
pure propaganda that there's something
far more suspicious going on here but
regardless
the other reason why i say this is
because loki
is not your average mcu concept
it's a lot more complex there's a lot
more nuance going there it's very
similar to wand division now one
division boiled down to a pretty simple
plot which is
it was agatha all along but also
i think loki is going to give us this
real first indication where we actually
see a show
that's as complicated as the main
character itself
loki's a very complex character and
giving us this kind of total shift from
the character that we're used to where
he's just
causing mischief and invading new york
and working for thanos and pissed off at
his family then instead there's a lot
more going on
because the loki's show is nothing else
if not a redemption arc for the
character of loki lofty son so
it's cool to see this happen and so i
think that there's going to be some huge
revelations that come out with what's
going on with lady loki and i think one
of the things that we're going to learn
here is that the time variants authority
are actually the bad guys they don't
know they're the bad guys they're
following the direction of the time
keepers but if i give you a series of
evil orders and you follow those
not knowing that they're evil then
they're still evil you're still a bad
guy
you just don't know that you're a bad
guy so i feel like that's kind of what's
going on here
it's possible i don't know if that's
definitively the case but the big thing
and i think the biggest takeaway from
this
is that you're probably asking yourself
if the reset chargers exist to prevent
alternate realities from coming into
existence then what would be the point
of sending them throughout different
places in the time stream
and how can they in turn create
alternate realities well you can
interpret this a couple different ways
the easiest and most convenient way to
interpret this albeit i think the wrong
way to interpret it is that the reset
chargers are just appearing at different
points throughout
time when they're not supposed to be
there and the same capacity of
loki and moby is having that
conversation in pompeii and moby is
saying
we're not supposed to be here we could
create a branch in the timeline by just
occupying this space
the reset chargers may very well be
functioning in the exact same way but
that kind of begs the question
what's the point because all they have
to do is just trace those back to their
genesis points and then in turn pick up
the reset charger and take it back
like maybe even reset the reset charger
and that's it the day's safe right you
could wrap the whole thing up in an hour
i think what's actually going on here
is the reset chargers are going back in
time and resetting
pivotal points throughout the time
stream what do you think would happen if
the reset charger went back in time
and landed in the room when steve rogers
was first being exposed
to the super soldier serum and they were
all obliterated from existence
and steve rogers never became captain
america what if peter parker never
became spider-man what if tony stark
never became iron man and that's just
earth right the avengers never form
there's no one there to stop thanos from
showing up on earth and taking the
infinity stone or possibly
invading asgard any number of things
could happen but these are now all
alternate realities that take place an
alternate reality where tony stark
doesn't exist where steve rogers doesn't
exist where peter parker doesn't exist
and alternate reality where scarlet
witch's powers are never woken up
and wanda maximoff just stays some crazy
revolutionary in sokovia and that's
it a reality where her brother never
died these are now
all alternate universes because those
critical moments in time
were altered they were adjusted they
were erased from existence
and so because of that things start
branching off and start going crazy
so the reset chargers one thing to
remember all they do is erase stuff from
existence
and by erasing things from existence
they keep that nexus event or that
variant timeline
from reaching the red line whereby it
officially becomes an alternate reality
and there's no going back right you have
that brief little moment once it
redlines it's officially an alternate
universe and there's no fixing it but as
long as they catch it before it gets to
that red line
then everything's okay i think that's
what loki's basically giving us right
like this
whole thing here with like all these
alternate realities spawning and popping
up
this is not going to be fixed right it's
not going to be reset and done and
ended by the time you get to the end of
the loki series instead it's going to
continue past the loki series
and likely into doctor strange 2 with
the multiverse of madness so
again it's going to be nuts and it's
going to be cool speaking of all these
little variant timelines
this brings us into our easter eggs and
the easter eggs that we have or at least
some of the ones we're going to talk
about here
actually support this case that that's
where the reset charges are going off
because if you look at the list of these
nexus points these nexus events that are
happening as they're popping up on the
screen
a lot of them are taking place in
significant moments throughout
the history of the mcu vormir sakar
different places like that these moments
where significant events took place
that could potentially alter or create
whole new realities based on what would
happen
if those moments never took place the
incredible hulk never landed on sakar
that the soul stone was never taken by
thanos
from vormir because you never saw gamora
tossed over the edge
the next thing i noticed is that in the
scene when loki is being assigned to
look up his varian and owen wilson says
he's going to go get something to eat
that there's actually the number 372
written in the background
that's a reference to thor issue number
372 when the tva
first appeared in the history of marvel
comics so that's a cool little moment to
recognize one of the other little
moments here is oshkosh wisconsin
that's where mark greenwald's from he's
the guy that created the time variance
authority that's also where the
superhero quasar wendell vaughn is from
which is a really cool moment because
i feel like turning into buzzfeed and
just being like are we going to see
wendell vaughn in the mcu
i don't know what do you think clickbait
like
i have no idea if that'd be the case or
not but it's a cool little reference
like a cool little little easter egg
going on there
the last big thing that i noticed in
terms of these easter eggs maybe in the
future we'll do like small little tiny
easter eggs because
there were a litany of those there were
multiple references to seven there's
actually a moment where a song is
playing that's a reference to the sims
game
which was composed by the guy who worked
with john favreau on iron man 2. so
there's all kinds of little small easter
eggs to go on there but
the other big one that i noticed was
reference to the avengers when loki was
looking up his file on the destruction
of asgard
the avengers as you guys know were like
meek and thor and hulk and valkyrie and
all those different characters
when they were basically escaping the
grand master the funny thing is the
revengers is also a reference to the
revengers team from the thanos
imperative story which is basically an
alternate reality
where nobody was able to die because
mistress death was killed
this led to the many angled ones so like
schumacher people like that
basically infiltrating that universe and
then turning everybody into twisted evil
versions of themselves
and they started calling themselves the
revengers but that's some of the cool
stuff that i noticed let me know in the
comments section what other little
easter eggs and things you guys noticed
because i'd love to see what you guys
spotted
and i will catch you all later peace